see these measures are in place so the
same thing doesn't doesn't happen what
happened in 1918 1919 can see this
Oxford Street and off the street is on
lockdown
look at this journey this road that I
travel on it all seems crazy over the
years I picked up thousands and
Tagalongs inspired by my story from a
juvenile with my clothes had holes in
them
I'm afro is picky - the night east
machine oh and Versace nice no laces
inner Archie's new millennium so first
day of partial lockdown of the UK found
out that my auntie whose condom and
health conditions both physical and
mental has got the virus she tested
positive to it she's at hospital I'm
gonna go about throughout my day through
London and show you guys what's exactly
going on the screen
reminds we're gonna share along the way
insha'Allah
so yeah let's see how the day goes
as we can see I had to come out to get
some stuff for the house a few stuff but
you can see that it it is slowly the
first day of the lockdown you can see
that it's becoming like a ghost town
less and less people on the streets
drastically all the restaurants are
closed all of them are closed as you can
see going past Green Lanes
and it's it's it's it's it's like this
surreal is that you're in a movie it's
like you're in a movie it's like who
would have thought or expected the
Western world Europe the superpowers -
all of a sudden within a matter of
months one month couple of weeks the
whole place is one absolute lockdown and
it is just the beginning and obviously
these measure in place sort the same
thing doesn't doesn't happen what
happened in 1918 1919 which was called
the space Spanish flu which some was
paid kind of declined Eva there was a
lot of deaths there that's one of the
reasons why stories say it's called
Spanish reboil there's no evidence I it
originated from there and some people
say it because of you know World War one
even though he it caused more deaths
than World War one about 50 100 million
people expected to have died from that
people bleeding from their nose and ears
that was some kind of next-level virus
which mutated and was spreading like
wildfire
you can see everywhere all shops are
closed everywhere but there is a sign
going on this is to let us know and I've
always wondered you know I would do it
all charity projects on Iman channel
where we raise funds for Palestine for
Syria for India you name it you know for
Ghana for all these places and I've
always wondered I always thought to
myself you know what we are just too
selfish we have become too selfish all
we care about is our own lifestyles
increasing our own lifestyle how could
we have better lifestyles comfort
comfort comfort and I'm not saying this
just because you know I'm some kind of a
peer sup you know I have this but I'm
just I would think to myself you know
what like I won't be surprised if I mom
was about to teach us a punishment
yeah it wasn't to teach us a lesson but
I always wanted how would that be
because unless the panel Tyler has his
Sunnah was his way of doing things but I
was for what would it be would there be
like a war in the UK or Euro World War
free and then we were realized what the
Syrian the Palestinians our brothers in
this is in Kashmir the Uighur Muslims
what would it be and I always wondered
to myself I'm not gonna do that would
cause us to fear not coming out
just as our promise is a fear of bombs
being dropped on them we live in a you
know in fear you know looking behind us
or you know having this fear food having
desperation for food so now it's like a
realization where allah subhanho wa
taala is working in such a mysterious
way but we cannot come out our houses in
not in fear of bombs being dropped but
the fear of another person somebody
covered rob has got the virus
I don't know if you can find anywhere so
we're gonna see in Charlotte
and it's you can just say nearly empty I
there's nobody there
you know what that's obviously the clean
that's the ways between this is what a
clean say yeah let's see if the queen is
in quarantine quarantine what can I go
and see if KFC's open father this one
had on ya didn't see mother taking
orders
Oh dominoes seems that there's a lot of
junk food or fast food places that are
open
so can't sit in what we're gonna take
away now my pee bucket you know I think
you some greasy food bother you know all
the luxuries of restaurants I we're not
going down this way for our food we're
gonna eat in the car and go check off
the food got the food from KFC but you
know how to touch the surface I had to
touch the door a few things that I'd
touch so if man now starts touching his
food and eating that that's gonna go
into my system so not only the Turkish :
yeah it's quite helpful in it
you know if you follow the before one of
the things which I don't know which one
who is after the how many one as far as
I know for my studies my teachers
watching this hopefully I don't get
refuted alcohol is not the edges it's
it's pure from on the station as a
humbly then Hamill is watching this
please do correct me but if not they're
not speak as far as I know it's not when
she follow the peanut it says and you're
using this you should just probably have
to do now this actually is a brief
little interesting I find our last math
teacher that's interesting
oh yeah so I'm gonna be in the car
you've been hit off the street guys it's
8:00 and it's Margaret time by the time
I get home I'll be late usually we have
the privilege of going to the massage it
it's a pray religious park is closed
this one I usually come to when I'm
doing a bar I'm on a break
but as you guys know it's closed but the
least I can do is pray at the doorstep
Alice is out the way you know instead of
because I'm used to doing
OOP I'm used to playing outside a lot so
instead of being in people's pathways
I'm just gonna have to pray right here
yes when I probably yeah I need to be
careful never there might be some Corona
thinking about for my jacket and pray so
not only do we lose the privilege of
restaurants that work at ETA now massage
it warm places playing a congregation
listen to the Quran it's not there
anymore
instead what you have to bring us to
play no excuses it's all guys we're
cooked now obviously I'm gonna you know
open air but you know what I just try
this on you know just to see how it is
but if you think about it even our one
of the things that I'm restricted is
fresh air
I can get fresh air but it's not the
same as breathing it in without the mask
so you can see we're even limited from
the food that we eat the place that was
from prey to the very oxygen that we
breathe because in this I feel like I'm
I'm inside I'm not outside I'm trying to
obviously it's not the same as part of
this offer I'm just a brief so for
example that pressure I'm breathing in
it's not the same when I have it on so
we can see this Oxford Street and Oxford
Street is on lockdown look at that see
that nobody's here absolutely dead and
this is Saturday night you know so yeah
so it just shows us how instantly what
light it's like surreal I feel I feel
like I'm in a movie though you guys feel
like you're in like a movie you know so
it's like a movie so
it's crazy look look around
need to be on a Saturday I'll be over
here I pick up customers it's rampant
busy people are still shopping what time
is it it's half 7:00
yeah half seven year at this time people
are shopping yeah so shopping stopped
clubbing stopped
restaurants have stopped everything
stopped like I said before honeymoon
reader so the process LM said which
shows us that he's a prophet so I'll
sell him because he said to us when
there's a click or something similar to
this
don't leave the place you're in if we
look at Italy one of the mistakes they
made is that they start panicking and
people that were hiring the virus what
it is this spreading yourself out we
went to different parts of Italy so what
is this so whatever it is they start
spreading out and they went to different
parts of the country and everyone's - I
get infected so what we learn from the
son of the person who sell them is that
when these kind of things happen
don't leave the place you're in yes stay
there and as we know like I was saying
before one of the signs of the day a
judgement is that a time would come
where you would want to give another
comment there's nobody even sabotage it
yet now when I look at stuff like this
and we would never in a million years
think that this would happen and so
Pamela is happening in our very in front
of our very own eyes so we're gonna take
a walk down Wall Street I've been few
people for the master plan is well you
know maybe we might speak to some people
but it's absolutely dead you know
so everywhere is closed except except
the waffle shop the war for the
workshops Alton shop is yeah well here
this shop is open dedicated to half
night
Wow yeah got people on the bikes real so
all right good
yes about people working yeah I'm gonna
head off to the studio cause few things
to do don't want to stay at home all day
what you guys you know
[Music]